good evening from London welcome to
Facebook with nonsense so whether you
like it or not many don't many do the
Middle East is hitting World sport like
a ballistic missile oil-rich states with
Bottomless Pits of cash are spending
Untold wods of their desert dollars on
buying up the games that we love they're
competing furiously with each other
they're transforming Sport and they're
just getting started Qatar plowed 220
billion dollars into the World Cup
formula one is in Saudi Arabia Bahrain
Qatar Abu Dhabi Dubai boasts major
boxing ballots that would have once been
a shoeing for Vegas or New York the
saudi-backed live golf has just turned
that sport upside down now it's
sensationally merging with the PGA Tour
and next societies are planning a
massive swing into professional tennis
and of course they want the biggest
sport of all football the beautiful game
well they're in the Premier League as
owners of Newcastle United and barely a
day seems to pass without another major
star following Cristiano Ronaldo to the
desert Kingdom for eye-watering Suns but
this Sporting Arms Race All Began
arguably with the UAE the emirati's
bought Manchester City back in 2008 it's
now become the jewel in the Middle East
sporting Crown City remodeling Club The
Ugly Duckling of Manchester forever in
the shadows of Manchester United but not
anymore it's United in the shadows of
city city have spent billions turning
City into the champions of Europe they
just beat my beloved Arsenal to the
Premier League title their seventh of
the shake mansaw it's a sore subject for
us gooners of course so you might think
perhaps like I do that there's something
wrong with it and maybe there is we'll
debate that later tonight but the key
question we're asking first is is it
fair was it a Level Playing Field did
Manchester City actually play by the
rules that had been laid down they've
now been charged with more than 100
breaches of Premier League Financial
regulations and tonight we're going to
reveal New Revelations which will
uncover a little bit more about those
charges well joining me now is the times
Chief Sports correspondent Matt Lawton
to talk us through it plus talk to you
the international editor isabello shot
and the former Vice chairman of Arsenal
David Dean and remotely by the
conservative MP and former chair of the
commons culture media and Sport
committee Damien Collins well thank you
all for joining me okay Matt tonight the
times is breaking a story which reveals
some detail of these charges against
Manchester City what is it and how
significant is it it's a specific detail
which is supported by documents it's
supported by the fact that there is a
new film that is obtained a UEFA report
that was into City these allegations of
financial doping if you like at
Manchester City
and specifically what you've got what
you've got to do if you roll back in
time
City awry these guys arrive and they
they own City
and they want they've got so much money
but there are rules that limit how much
they can spend it so the allegations
really are around the fact that whether
they were using slightly underhand ways
to spend the money faster to to close
the gap on on the arsenals in the
Manchester United's quicker in this
specific case what we have are two
payments of 15 million pounds in 2012
and 2013 so 30 million in total by a
mystery figure now UEFA looked at this
person uh Yaba Muhammad and they
couldn't actually identify who he was
but what's what's important about this
story is the fact that actually when it
came to it a lot of what UEFA looked at
when they investigated Manchester city
was time barred and they had a five-year
limit that's not the case with the
Premier League and we're pretty certain
that of the 115 charges that sit that
City are facing from the Premier League
and that's the thing when we talk about
City winning the winning the treble two
and a half weeks ago it's hard you have
to still look at it within the context
of these charges that are hanging over
them we're pretty confident this will be
one of the charges and this is the kind
of thing just just this random simple
Layman's language just shoving money
there's 30 million pounds have come in
from this mystery donor who's not an
official sponsor no he's and who do we
think he is who do we think he
represents well we think he's not far
removed from the you know from the
people that run the countries and if
that is the case is that a clear breach
of premier league rules yes because it
because it's not a sponsorship deal it's
not legitimate ship deal the point is
when you are City in 2012 2013 you you
know in 2023 they are now the richest
club in the world the most successful
they attract all the sponsorship they
attract all the money because they're
winning everything so everyone wants to
sponsor them but back then even though
they were going to win the title
um you know they're winning their first
title back then they're not commanding
the sums they need to spend far yeah
that Squad that Pep Guardiola has just
won the trouble with Costa the best part
of a billion pounds to assemble so
you've got to spend that money and they
had to spend money fast to get into a
position where they could really what
are the repercussions if they're found
guilty of a number of these charges like
the one that the times is reporting
tonight if they're found guilty what
happens well the the the options open to
the Premier League are pretty extensive
including relegating them from the
Premier League would they remove this
recently won premier league title and
would that automatically go to the club
that came second well unfortunately for
Arsenal the the the the the the the span
of the time span of the charges is 2009
to to to 2018. but you could argue the
whole edifice has been built on what
they did in those first few years
absolutely if that was all done
illegally breaking the rules of the
Premier League it's pretty serious I
mean David look you've been at the
Forefront of all this one of the Premier
League's great you know creators what do
you make of this I'm not sure how much
of a Smoking Gun this really is in the
scheme of things and whatever you say
Manchester City and I'm not here to
defend Mansion City they've done a
sensational job not just for themselves
but for the Premier League 115 charges I
understand that then they've still got
to be proven yet don't they but only one
of them here out of 150 30 million oh no
they're innocent until proven guilty
sure there's a lot of long way to go yet
they'll probably travel along for the
next couple of years in any case I
cannot see them having any titles taken
away from them I think that would be
wrong in the scheme of things but let's
see uh what the argument is we're going
to come back to the I want to come back
to the wider debate about this Sports
washing concept but let me bring in a
Damian Collins so Damien what do you
make of this this whole situation around
city and the sort of central charge I
guess that these 115 charges which
they're facing relating to the first few
years that they were involved with this
big takeover by shaped man saw if it
turns out that they really were
masking and concealing vast sums of
money which has then led to them
becoming the biggest club in the world
what should be done about this
well there should be some sanction
against them and I think that can't just
be a fine which will be irrelevant to
Manchester city has to be some sort of
in-game sanction and I think these 115
charges aren't a trivial matter
sometimes when you hear people talking
about this it makes it sound like this
is these are details for lawyers this is
about the Integrity of the competition
if clubs are willingly breaking the
rules for their own advantage to give
them a competitive Advantage within
those sporting competitions they have to
be robust sporting sanctions I think it
also shows there has to be proper robust
independent Financial oversight of
football clubs as well I think too much
of this takes place within the sport and
also it's too easy for very wealthy
clubs to use lawyers to frustrate
investigations for years it needs to be
much more transparent than it's been so
far I mean the bottom line is that
clubs should be state-owned right but a
lot of clubs are already it looks to me
circumnavigating that they're sort of
setting up entities which are clearly
linked to States and they're getting
around it that way should we be
tightening the loopholes on this
yeah I think that's that's why we need
to have this much discussed football
regulator in the UK where there's proper
transparency of financial records this
isn't just done within the sporting
competitions themselves but actually
there's an external body that's got the
right to know who's who are the ultimate
owners of the club where are the funds
coming from are they trading within the
financial Fair player rules because what
a lot of fans will feel is a club is
bought effectively by a sovereign wealth
fund we're a very rich entity billions
of pounds are pumped in and where's that
money going for how's it being spent
because it distorts the competition for
everyone else if clubs are breaking the
financial rules and what we've got to
avoid I think is football being owned by
a very small number of people who are
the only people who've got the resources
to buy some of these clubs and operate
them and the way they're being run now
right Isabel let's look at this in a
bigger picture of sports washing this
new phrase
I'm kind of torn on it because I think
there's obviously a degree of sports
washing obviously a lot of these Middle
Eastern countries would like to improve
their images particularly the ones like
Saudi they've got you know poor human
rights records and so on and it's right
they should be held accountable for the
human rights abuses and so on but it's
also true I've seen it with my friend
Cristiano Ronaldo over in Saudi the
amazing impact he's been having on
football there but also the reaction of
the young Saudi football fans they're
football nuts over there and we saw the
Qatar World Cup teams like Morocco and
others huge oh who
SE huge rest in the region uh why should
they not be able to go around the world
investing in sport that their own people
absolutely love what is intrinsically
wrong with that even if along the way
there is clearly an element of sports
watching well as Damien Collins was
saying there it's about transparency
isn't it and I think you make a very
fair point here about the actual impact
that it's having back in those countries
and I think to me what this shows is the
astonishing level
is in the Middle East at the moment I
mean several countries that are plowing
huge sums of money into getting involved
in sport as part of a kind of whole
overhaul of their International image
for geopolitical reasons and the
government here has I think rightly
taken a very pragmatic view of that you
know taking Saudi Arabia as an example
we basically need them you know we must
we still we still have arms deals with
Saudi Arabia 40 we still buy 40 percent
of our oil from Saudi Arabia the qataris
own half of London I mean there's a lot
of hypocrisy I found around the Qatar
World Cup I mean Matt if you come to the
way that journalists in this country
have covered all this it's a lot of like
a sort of angry reaction from British
journalists about sports watching and
how wrong it all is but ultimately if
you are City fans you ask Newcastle fans
you ask gold fans we're not going to see
their biggest Styles in the world come
together for some collective competition
whatever it may be if you ask most
sports fans
about the huge injections of cash I
don't think there is morally problematic
about it as perhaps journalists here are
I think we were right just as you've
done it just now I think we were right
to to question some of the human rights
issues going into Qatar and even before
the football started
um particularly when they're
confiscating rainbow hats off people and
stuff like that the sort of PR own goals
that were happening but if that's their
culture you know you can't expect to go
into another country and they have they
are concerning them on the World Cup in
1966 it was actually illegal to be gay
in this country well you know how would
we have felt if people to come along
with rainbow Flags then they'd have been
taken down they'd have been arrested so
I do think you have to actually evolves
yeah but I do think the idea that
England in particular it takes
we invaded Iraq illegally in my opinion
it's just my opinion invaded Iraq
illegally uh caused Mayhem in the Middle
East and yet somehow we think we are
morally pure enough to lecture the
Middle East about how they should
conduct
ever bought that argument particularly I
think the reporting was balanced because
the messaging before the World Cup was
that everyone was welcome and then
people were made to feel they weren't
welcome and you know we interviewed gay
football fans out there who didn't feel
welcome anyway but but that's not that
because you told them they were well
because what I found on the streets of
cancer I was having a great time it was
you going up to gay people saying do you
feel welcome wasn't it
you know I would read some of the stuff
but anyway
um look it's on Sports washing generally
yeah is there a line between genuine
Sports watching which I'm sure they're
all trying to do wash their human rights
records improve their image but also
genuine recognition that they really do
want to get involved in sport and
actually if the sport benefits like golf
tremendously from Grassroots up from
vast injections of cash do we care look
I live in Manchester and I've been
covering the Manchester United Sales
first seven months now
um the majority of Manchester United
fans want the qataris to win this yeah
battle because they just see an
opportunity to to be out back back up
with the big boys in terms of spending
in terms of being able to take on what
they see as a Potential Threat well a
clear threat from Newcastle down the
line but more more locally from
Manchester City right so so they that so
they want that um I think it is you know
the horse is bolted I think they're here
to stay I sat with representatives of
the Saudis when I was in Qatar I sat
with the qataris they want the World Cup
in in Saudi Arabia yeah they want the
Olympics yes you know David let me bring
you in a lot of business around the
world right we met we had a nice cup of
tea in Qatar and it was an amazingly
well-run World Cup everyone had a great
time I thought I thought the best Graham
Sooners told me the best you've been to
um but there is there are obviously
political issues here you can't divorce
politics and Sport obviously some of
these countries like Saudi Arabia have
very bad records on human rights and you
can't ignore that in all this and
obviously they're trying to improve
their image where's the line for you
well there is a balance firstly how do
you stop overseas investment and it's
been going on for years you take
Rolls-Royce cars who owns the
Rolls-Royce one of the
what the best times in English car
manufacturer who owns it BMW who who
owns
um Harrods the state of Qatar who owns
Coleman's mustard if you like that's art
subject who I you know who Unilever of
Holland so you're always going to get
overseas invest we're going to your
newspaper mat I mean we're not making a
huge fuss about the fact that the
Chinese have huge stakes in our critical
National infrastructure I mean that's
arguably much more worrying than
anything that we're seeing here and the
point you made about the Saudis wanting
to get their own people involved I've
looked at their Vision 2030 an
incredible plan for how they're going to
transform in every little way and it's
it's from the big to the small for
example they want to raise life
expectancy from 74 to 80 there they've
got very specific plans about how much
sport they want everybody to be doing
every week I think it would it would
behold the UK to slightly reduce our
moral High Ground on this because
honestly there isn't called Financial
FAIR Plan existence yeah so there there
is a leveling and it's meant to and it
will work eventually if you put ready
but if these charges against City are
true or even half of them are true they
have trampled all over that's that's
another story and as I say that's yet to
be proven
you what I mentioned two quick things
before we let you uh oh that's very kind
yes
um if we can talk football for two
minutes
so I'm on two two campaigns to do with
football one is time keeping because you
know how long it takes to score a goal
mat four minute all right four man move
guy scores how long does it take
35 seconds 10 seconds okay so when they
when the fourth official puts up three
or four minutes is the accurate the last
10 seconds no he's not I want that the
time loss I'm not talking about four
minutes and get rid of VAR which has
been I'm a great believer in Vaughn I
think it helps the referees we're all
talking I think until the joy out of
football we'll have to disagree on that
one because come back another time we'll
debate okay so anyway I'm on time
keeping I want to eventually see real
time I want the fans to realize they're
gonna get 60 Minutes of actually pure
football I think fans would agree what's
the other one that's another one the
other one is penalty shootouts believe
it or not why is it that the penalties
are taken at one end which has to be a
disadvantage to the opposing team I want
to see penalties taken at either end so
let's take the Cup Final you have Man
City taking their penalties
so at least the no you take it at your
own at where you've got 20 or 30 000
families you're depriving me of the joy
of watching somebody from Tottenham
taking your penalty against also and
fifty thousand I was booing at him well
yeah and I don't want you doing that how
does a penalty how does he feel how the
fans at the wrong end of the pitch feel
when they've got to watch it down the
other end well look as always you're an
innovator you always have been that's
why my club's in such a great condition
thanks to you and all you did so thank
you again for that thank you very much
great story tonight it's going to be
very interesting how this all plays out
when we get more details of more of
these charges Isabel thank you as always
for your perspective if you'd like to
watch and thank you to Damon as well for
joining us Damon Collins over there I
appreciate it if you want to watch
Britain's biggest football Scandal it's
available on YouTube now and it has more
of this story about Manchester City